I think we will we will be able to lift
it this year
I hope
but
the next meeting of the emergency
committee is on
either in a month I think because as you
know they meet every three months
so it should be early May there will be
a meeting of the emergency Committee of
kovid
and they will deliberate so I think
without full access to the information
that China has you know you cannot say
this or that all hypotheses are on on
the table that's who's position and
that's why we have been asking China to
to be
cooperative on on on this
um if they would do that then we will
know uh what happened or how it started
so we have molecular evidence that
animals were sold at the juanan market
we also know that within the samples
that tested positive for SARS cov2 there
was evidence of DNA from animals and
some of those animals are known to be
susceptible to SARS cov2 infection so
these are Clues and these are clues that
we use to better understand the
potential exposures to humans in terms
of how they may have been infected early
on in the pandemic it doesn't give us
any concrete answers or answer all of
the questions but it does give us some
clues in terms of what the intermediate
hosts may be and potentially how
important and we knew the huanon market
was an amplifying event but we don't
know if that was the exact start of this
pandemic further information that we
need and we have been requesting for
years now is where did those animals
come from where were they farmed how did
they enter into the market was this
through was this wild animals domestic
animals how were they traded where do
they come from were they tested were the
individuals who worked in the market
um were there serologic tests that were
done from people who were working in the
market who are working on the farms we
don't have any of those answers and so
what we're trying to do is work with
Scientists for more to learn more
information about the earliest cases the
earliest cases of covid-19 that occurred
in November perhaps even earlier than
that